[Music]
hello everybody it's nice to be back and
we're going to start with a special
special treat because since since 2011
there was a big surprise
can anyone tell me what big surprise
happened in 2011 considered
coincidentally it also happened in
England
Gibraltar what happened in 2011 hint
Korchnoi was involved that was the time
he played Khurana at the age of can
somebody help me with the age yes around
80 actually 79 Korchnoi Juan so that was
a big huge upset basically six years ago
and now the biggest upset of this year
happened at isle of man chess calm open
and what was that who was the big hero
of the tournament james Tarjan and
what's amazing about this that Tarjan
just came back from retirement so in
honor of this great achievement
obviously we're going to go through this
now legendary game that he played
against kramnik but first I want to show
Tarr John's famous and really good end
games that I found and I want to share
with all of you so Torian is famous for
being what a librarian yes but mostly
for being an Olympic medalist he's the
he's part of the team of the first gold
medal team and in fact his opponent
Larry evens the second of Bobby Fischer
was his teammate so in this game not
surprisingly it's going to be a Sicilian
because Sicilian was a big thing in the
70s and eight
because of tall also later on there'll
be carpet of course no matches where we
wear the dragon will be featured Knight
takes d4 Knight f6 Knight c3 e six g4
can somebody tell me what opening is
this the carats attack so it was a big
thing then so h6 that was really popular
Kasparov second was kind of
experimenting with this especially with
h4 and h5 and long theory happened but
here there's an age-old idea for white
that Torian played that's not really
played these days everyone plays h3 h4
was the modern one g5 exactly g5 is so
old that I was scanning through in for
mater's and that's how I knew about the
move g5 and I actually played it in a
junior tournament and I drew 2500 then I
was like 23 50 so g5 is actually a very
exciting move and I'm actually showing
this game it will eventually transpose
into an endgame so you can see how thar
Jon has an exact plan how to aim for
positional pressure which will
eventually lead to wonderful and game
for him so H takes Bishop takes g5
knight c6 how should we continue Knight
this Knight takes c6 B takes c6 e v is
an interesting idea but we can come back
to action later and that's what he did
he played Queen d2 a6 and now castles
yeah Queen c7 h4 now h4 is a very deep
idea it's kind of preparing the pressure
on the e6 pawn which will be very
important for the whole game Bishop d7
how should we continue here if we're
trying to pressure on the e6 square
yeah Bishop h3 and the main idea will be
very apparent soon Bishop e7 how should
we continue now f4 yeah like a caveman
f4 and after takes takes castle king be
one king b f5 and this looks very very
cave mannish but it's a very deep idea
that thar John has the point is he wants
to soften the e6 pawn so it will move
now evens obliges and lets the d5 square
weakened and that will be it basically
Queen f2 now there's the basic threat
what is white threatening right now yeah
Bishop takes f6 Bishop takes f6 I will
show you if black will play something
terrible as Bishop c8 white would take
on f6 Bishop takes f6 and I d5 that
knight on d5 is a monster and even if
white would lose the h4 pawn it doesn't
really matter because that night just
Dominus dominates the game so evens has
to do his best to stop that so he plays
Bishop c6 now this is what Tarjan was
really good and you see in the eventual
games he knows when to rush things and
when not to rush action how should he
continue right now
Brooke g1 would be a bit suspicious on
accounts of Knight takes e4 the pawn is
a bit loose at the moment so we need to
defend that
so he plays Bishop g2 defends ed rook c8
Bishop f3 trying to hint at the idea of
h5 h6 which would destabilize the knight
on f6 b5 which is kind of threatening
before and another very nice
prophylactic move happens here a3 no
more be for ideas actually the favor
small Moldovan Grand Master once said if
b5 happens and Bishop e7 a3 is always a
nice move to make because it will stop B
for ideas forever
and it will actually stop B for ideas
forever surprisingly should be seven
Rudy's Rudy - Rudy 851 rook d7 and now
Bishop takes f6 with the idea of
exchanging tonight's Queen a7 and now
there's a big dilemma for white should
he exchange Queens or not who says we
should exchange Queens raise your hand
if you think we should exchange Queens
well if you let's see if takes King
takes you do in the pawn but that pawn
is basically worthless on d6 at the
moment so well we have an opposite
colored Bishop ending coming up so it
all depends on the future where you can
potentially put your pieces there can
why potentially put his pieces that
could actually be decisive in the long
run if we would have some magic powers
where could we pose this Bishop where
would we put it on d5 yes it would be a
god there
but how could we achieve it in a long
term in the long term yeah exactly rule
D - Bishop d1 c3 Bishop e3 so it could
be achieved
so should we exchange Queens now should
we should we wait or just keep the
Queen's on
what's black planning to do in the long
term does he have any big plans yeah he
has some plans on doubling on the sea
line but can white kind of counter that
yeah so it's not a big deal
so taja undecided to take on a seven
King takes yeah and now defended upon
because especially in end games just
defend your pieces it's the most
important thing because you don't have
many pieces left and how else you gonna
make your opponent if you don't have
pieces left
rook c6 c3 King b7 rogue g1 now rook g1
this move I really like because
basically it stops black from ever
bringing out the bishop and also
planning to maneuver the bishop through
d1 to b3 king c7 rook d2 but notice that
taja and realized I have time I don't
need to hurry you can't do anything
you're just waiting for me to just
slowly destroy your position so just
enjoy have a tea and watch how I just
crush you rook d8 and now comes the
brilliant move Bishop d1 king D 7 Bishop
b3 and now we achieved the dream
position and can we say that white is
winning well not yet but slowly slowly
black is losing oxygen because he's
running out of ideas
King g7 Bishop d1 now this might look
like a mysterious move and I admit it is
a mysterious move but it actually
emphasizes the fact that black can't
really do anything it all depends on
what white wants to do and this is more
uncomfortable than it looks because in a
chess game
your time is ticking you you're trying
to find some coherent plan for black but
you can't there is no in this position
yeah he is basically in sis mom so white
can get away with kind of maneuvering
and just probe in black a little bit
look C for Bishop f3 just kind of
stating that I will chase you away
eventually
a5 King gay - where is that king headed
was probably to b3 rook b8 king b3 and
now black doesn't venture and doesn't go
this far but he could actually try a
four and even though it looks like
counterintuitive move because you're
supposed to put your pawns mostly on
black squares so the white bishop can't
reach it but in this case it would stop
white from developing and initiative on
the Queen side and the only way I could
be able to open up the position is to
eventually blow up the position with c4
but then d8 a3 b2 pond also gets weak
rooks e6 but larry even sticks to the
waiting principle which is also a very
good way of defending because if your
position is sound enough the way you can
defend like slightly worse positions is
not to move many of your pieces if you
believe that your position is safe you
can so-called sit and just wait and say
okay you're a wonderful player you might
be a champion or something but I'll be
wait you out and you have no chance of
beating me but okay sergeant says I'll
beat you somehow slowly Bishop e2 rugby
six rook d5 big improvements are in
progress the rook actually occupied the
important square and now we can sense
the weakness which is that glaring
weakness in blacks position that juicy
b5 pawn now the problem is black would
love to play b4 but then we'd take take
create a passed pawn and that pawn will
decide the game because this extra
bishop basically who has no opposition
whatsoever will just act as an extra
piece and that's how white will win the
game yeah exactly like you say the
bishop on f6 is totally out of the game
it's kind of biting granite at the
moment biding on the e5 pawn which is
not useful in chess at least King the
seven rook d1 and you can see how slowly
tariana coordinates his pieces he does
not hurry King c7 rook G one and this is
seemingly this is a waiting move
seemingly this is in osius but it's kind
of playing with your opponent asking so
what are you going to do next he has all
of his pieces lined up for defense but
now he will have to move one of those
pieces out of the best practical
positions and that's why sometimes like
great grandmasters wait around and move
around like Nakamura and Caruana
because they want to force their
opponents to discomfort their pieces
King D 7 and that King doesn't really
belong on d7 it would rather be on c7
rook d1 king c7 king c2 Bishop g5 rubgy
one Bishop f6 and now Tarjan decided
it's time to make the splendid move
and he just puts another squeeze in the
position
how can he tighten the the squeeze on
black here before exactly now it's very
interesting in chess that sometimes you
have to make moves that contradict
themselves why am I putting all my pawns
on black squares well I have no other
choice this is the only way I can fix
this weakness on b5 and for that I'm
even willing to put a pawn on black
square because in order to win a game
you need at least two weaknesses from
your opponent now b5 there's one f5 is
one and actually to win this game white
will be able and will need to open up a
line otherwise if there's no entry to
the blacks position it would be a draw
obviously a takes b4 and now this is
also an important decision and then
actually a dilemma which pawn to take
with you take with the a pawn it's true
if you take with the a pawn he can't
capture the a line on the other hand
even an opposed colored Bishop rook and
games
you're always aiming for a passer
yeah and that case we'll take with the
seafoam yes I mean a is also fine cuz
eventually we might keep the beep on and
just roll with with it with the c4 break
I'll so let's say eight eggs before King
moves and slowly will build up enough
pressure and defense on the b4 pawn that
we'll be able to play C for let's say
something like rugby 1 and C 4 and maybe
b5 ideas let's say king c 7c for takes
b5 it's a bit of a counterintuitive
defense but I have even enough defenders
on b5 and I'll take on c4 later now the
other thing that what really needs to be
careful is not to allow black to build a
blockade because if the bishop somehow
could get to b6 draw wouldn't be too far
away so taryeong decides to take with
the C pawn and this actually achieves
two things one potentially we might have
a passed pawn and two will have the C
line for action route b7 how can we get
the C Line
yeah when he played King b2 but King b3
is also okay King b8 rogue g3 another
little bit of a twist in this King g3
move why it is in no hurry of letting
the bishop out to g5 because if you just
let the ghost out just once just once
it'll get activated and it might cause
problems later on
rook g3 King c7 Bishop d1 King b7 rook
c3 and now when the black can crossed to
the Queen side then James sorry on
decides to cut off the king and now it
is a very good moment because he'll
either have to exchange a rook but then
the b5 pawn will be weak forever or wait
and just see his own demise which will
happen pretty slowly
rook c7 takes takes Bishop b3 Bishop g5
rook d3 now like managed to put the
bishop on g5 but it's already too late
rook d3 a very good move it defends
against Bishop maneuvers to d4 which
would be annoying while also planning to
ship the rook to the sea line Bishop d5
Bishop h6 Brooks III King b8 and now
comes a very good liquidating move by
Tariana
yeah rook c6 yeah yes and otherwise he
can't even defend himself because if the
King moves then just check and then
slowly the King will move up a four and
it's totally busted so he has to take
but that's basically the end of the game
because as we know and opposite colored
end games the two passers decide the
game so King b6 Bishop c4 King c6
King b3 Bishop d2 check a4 a5 and King
gave four and a brilliant game by
Thierry on what was really amazing and
what I really like is his use of the
King I'm gonna show more games where he
uses his King to full effect and even in
this game he first brings his King then
he pushes the pawn because he knows that
these pawns and end games need these
supports to actually be powerful enough
to win it otherwise if the pawns would
have been pushed too far let's say if I
play a really donkey move like b5 King
c5 a for Bishop a5 and oops we can agree
to a draw and enjoy our days but toejam
was more clever and plans to bring the
King first then push the pawn on the
black squares in this way the King can
help the pawns move further forward and
then that way he won tariana is known
for his 1976 gold medal a very very
strong team so here he plays the
legendary bent Larsen and he is
obviously a pawn down so he's not gonna
win this game but he is going to save it
against such a legend as bent Larsen
been played rook III the great
Scandinavian player and now tari on
plays Knight c2 rock age 3 rookie - now
notice that he brings all of his pieces
to defense and that's how you supposed
to play an endgame use as many of your
forces as possible to pull your position
together notice that he's upon down so
he needs the extra forces to defend the
position Knight age 4 how can we
potentially stop the idea of Knight f3
94 pretty nice active move bringing the
knight to the center and also trying to
hint that active play if necessary
Knight f3 maybe not the best move
because as there is this common saying
all rook end games are drawn Knight f3
wasn't the best idea most probably a
King move coming closer would have been
better Knight f3 takes takes and now bed
Larsen is kind of preparing to bring the
King closer how can't Ariane stop that
rook g2 yes so there's two way of
playing these end games first you want
to achieve your own Goldmann to a second
and not least you want to stop all of
your opponent's plants so okay he wanted
to play King GC so he plays rook f4 and
King III and then g5 now Darian felt
that his position is a little bit
passive so he activates his rook rook g3
King g6 rook h3 the plan he had in mind
I think is to bring the rook behind the
black King and start annoying been
Larson vacek's now he played rook h4 and
now comes a dilemma
which is always difficult whether to
enter the endgame or not obviously we
don't have a choice here if you take our
rook away we'll lose the pawn so we'll
have to take g2x h4 and we'll still have
to calculate here because if we
calculate badly we lose now James our
young calculated perfectly and found a
pretty spectacular draw in this position
King F for the first move is correct h3
I'm not sure king f4 f5 yeah it could it
might be the idea of keeping the pawn on
h2 till the opportune moment so he
played King III King f7 and there is a
thing called distant opposition King f3
and obviously these are top-level GM's
of the 70s and 80s so they know that
yeah there there should be some even
numbered squares yeah these yeah yes so
King e6 has been played here we block
again can get for King f6 and now he
comes up with a real really really good
counterintuitive idea
yeah he will make a king move what the
question is where King III why is King
III so illogical because it it is it is
so illogical yeah it loses our position
so why did he do that what did he miss
or did he miss something
so King he 5 was played King f3 f4 how
did he continue
he can't go to g4 cuz then the King goes
to e4 and the pawns just marches in well
he continued with his plan
King he too kinky for king f2 f3 king g1
King III King f1 f2 and what now
h3 and sadly for bent Larsen there's no
more moves for him apart from King f3
which is a draw so the whole point of
whites play was realizing that he has
this extra h3 pawn move which he can use
as a stalemate trick and then actually
is a drawn position so this was an
extremely nice save against the top
player like bent Larsen in the 80s 79
80s and this one is also very nice when
this will be a heavy piece end game he
plays King g7 after king h2 and what's
great about King g7 is that he's asking
okay everything I have is in good
position
I just improve my pieces slowly getting
my King a bit closer for the endgame
rook c5 takes takes and white manages to
exchange off this important piece on b5
but where can black find the weaknesses
in White's position
yell near b1 b2 a2 is the weakest of all
the pawns in this position but we have a
rook here on EA t' that does nothing so
taryeong comes up with a pretty amazing
idea here yes Queen B 1 that's what he
played first easily and rook e8 his plan
as simple as it may look is Roo k-6
rook b6 as just you said and after that
white will be kind of hogtied and will
be will not be able to move at all
kingi to Luke a6 rugby 6 Queen d2 and
now he plays rook b5 a really good move
because he's slowly trying to improve
his pieces and a way for the opportune
moment to strike he's not in any rush to
get white out of this trouble
Ruby 5 Queen e2 King g8
he's waiting also he doesn't want to get
into checks that's why he moves his King
to g8 Queen d2 King h7 King g7 he's kind
of Tang going around playing with his
opponent Abed
Queen d2 Queen a - Queen e2 Queen b3
hindi to rugby 6 so the rook has done
its job now so it goes back King g8 King
g1 Luke a6 rooks e3 Queen King b6 now
the constant waiting is taking a toll on
white and he's breaking so he decides to
act we should have waited but it's kind
of frustrating just to defend your
position constantly efore D takes Queen
takes recruit b6 now this was a real
Grand Master trick Black was kind of
giving the impression that oh I gave up
on the idea of invading on the queenside
he moved all his theses back and when
his opponent said oh okay you gave up on
the idea of assaulting me on the
queenside he says haha not not that way
and he's coming back with Deric to b6
rookie five beam f6 and now even though
this check looks pretty aggressive
that's nothing is just a check the King
will move to g7 and the Queen defense
likes position quite well
we need to rugby three and now the
position improved dramatically for black
because before the position was closed
it was difficult to get close to White's
pawns but after this
efore opening the d4 pawn is visibly
weak King G to Queen d6 rookie for King
g7 not in a rush bringing the King
closer because what happens if it
eventually would turn into an endgame f3
Queen d5 King h2 and now Taran decided
it was time what did he play here
Queen Bee five it was the right moment
to play creme b5 exactly because the
king was perfectly placed on g7
everything was ready for the exchange
and also mind you the black the black
king is better now on g7 and the King on
h2 and my just move the King away from
the Queen side which will be decisive
take stakes rookie to rugby three and
actually a double attack will occur
because after if white will play King g2
instead of rook c2 then black can
already play rook d3 and the d4 pawn
will hang and will be dropped because if
rookie seven then we have check first
then we can take on beta so tarean
slowly squeezed the life out of whites
position and now he's winning upon rook
takes f3
Brooksie for Czech takes King f6
and look if the King would be on g8 it
would be an extra temple to go to f6 but
because of the exact timing of Tae Yong
the King can come and crawl up to the
center to d5 threatening pawn wins on d4
rookie hate King e6 rook e8 King d6 can
get fate King g7 but also he's not in
any hurry
he's a pawn up so he doesn't need to
rush with the attack rook b8 King g6 a
for king d5 now this is a this is the
way you play and games
you bring your king when the endgame
comes and actually the difference is
striking this King on h3 is measurable
on the side you can't even get out as
you pointed out because if g4 then just
Ruby 3 check and then white loses so
basically black has a king advance
a five rugby five what is trying a
little trickery with a six ideas because
if like if we would take a six happens
and the B to Brooke would be hanging but
target says no no no no tricks Luke the
eight
kingi for room d7 Luke takes a five king
takes c4 c5 now after you have an
amazing King in the center supporting
your pawn sometimes the quality of your
pawn is more important than the measly
pawns that you have left
obviously you defend it if you can but
in this case this pawn is just so fast
it doesn't really matter if he takes on
g6 or not he takes but it really doesn't
matter
rook d5 and this is the other reason
active Kings are useful the King can
support rook so when he would try to get
under our pawn we just stop it with rook
c5 and now the only thing left to do is
hide with our King preferably not in
front of our pawns
so how do we even after Brooke d6 check
if you move your king to C for you you
block your pawn a little bit it's still
a good move but it's not what we desire
our main threat is to just rush with the
pawn and just Queen ya King III rookie
six King F two King g1 and while
trapping the White King on h3 c2 c1
queen is unstoppable that's a superb
King
the king is a finding piece exactly so
the other important game I wanted to
show was against his fellow player
fellow winner at the Olympia's of the 76
Olympiads Kubelik well we could say it's
around equal slightly better for black
for this for the reason that the pawns
are pretty weak on beforehand efore
so he plays Bishop e7 queen c5 and now
he does something that is very
noteworthy
he fixes wide structure how did he do
that
notice that all of the pawns in front of
the White King is on black squares
apart from the e4 pawn which is pretty
weak she's a good news
so he played h5 which is a beautiful
psychological trick
the reason is Kubelik played queen c5
that the intention of taking on b6
trying to liquidate and carry on gave a
choice saying okay you can liquidate but
then I'll fix your structure you can
choose maybe you can take on h5 but then
I'll get a passed pawn or you don't take
my pawn and I get to fix your structure
and it worked like a charm
because carbolic wanted to exchange the
Queen's even at the cost of h5 now the
great idea of h5 is that in the long run
these pawns on the King side will be
pretty weak f3 and now another great
idea pops up in tirean's head and plays
another fixing move
'if five is an option he found a
different one which one B 5 B 5 fixes
the b4 bond but also puts the pawn in
danger because of Bishop F ones and
hitting on like B 5 would run into
bishop f1 ideas pressuring on b5 how can
we put pressure on the e4 pawn f5 and
the point is that absolute takes takes
this Bishop is very much alive while
that Bishop is dead and has to cover the
f3 pawn before that f3 was trying to
help this Bishop get get a defender so
it can move away to f1 so f5 takes takes
at 4 he's actively trying to exchange
but Torian doesn't mind takes takes King
f7 as we seen before the King is key in
the end games and the difference of the
Kings will decide King f2 king g6 King
III King d5 the rook was already well
positioned on d4 kind of tying down the
rock on b1 King d5 also brings the King
closer while also shutting out the White
King from entering the Queen side rook
c1 he decides to sacrifice upon I
wouldn't say losing the pawn because he
wants to get active and try to put some
pressure on the black pawns Brooke c1 he
takes the pawn obviously check g6 in
general don't leave your pawns and pre
if you don't have a good reason why had
a good reason he want to get wanted to
get a active rook d7 King zc6
route g7 rookie for check he has this
check and gives this check for one
reason to defend the pawn
and also rookie four has another idea
please tell me which side you're going
either you're going to the queenside
trying to stop the beep on or you go
back to the F line trying to defend the
kingside pawns you have to choose when
the King was on III white could decide
depending on the situation where he
wants to go so he chose to go d3 rookie
six King Defour b5 and now we can see
that both the rock and King works and
coordinates pretty well in this position
rook b8 rook d6 check another question
where are you heading to
which way are you going so it decides to
go to c3 if he would go to e5 there's a
very good idea here I'm sure Tom was
preparing to play that what could black
do here
yes King c5 and the good thing with this
King c5 move is obviously it doesn't
lose because we can just push the rook
to c6 will cut your King off and we just
push the pawn till at Queen's hopefully
it does and it will so he can't go to
ePHI just because of this King c5 and he
would be cut off so he can't get too
active which is important if he would
get active he would get some drawing
chances king c3 King D 5 our king is
kind of saying okay we're going for your
pawns yeah
King d3 King c5 check now notice he
could have played king c5 but that
doesn't really pose much questions it's
pretty obvious what's your intentions
after king c5 their king d5 King the
three king c5 why again we'll have to
decide am I going to defend my pawns or
am I going to stop the beep on so he
decides to stop the beep on King c-4
this is a better move than king d4 I
think because it's closer to the beep on
also prepares b4b three ideas
rook c8 King D four and what a surprise
the same idea King the rook e8 King D 2
was also an option rook e8 rook c6 check
in d2 b 4 would be 8 king c4 king c2
root k 6 and slowly-slowly taureanas
pushing cover leg down rook c8 King D
for rugby 8 but now black decides it's
time to give away the b-pawn because
there's too many defenders there but
look there's no one defending the King
side so he goes for those pawns rook g2
takes King III check King f2 and
suddenly black shifts all his pieces to
the Kings side and takes all the pawns
takes rubgy 4 takes check chasing the
King away takes on h4 and this is
trivial because two pawns should be
winning and in this case even though he
gave up the h5 pawn the f1 is just
strolling in kinky two doesn't work
because of rookie forecheck so this was
another good example of him using the
King and as a finishing touch I want to
show the game that was the sensation of
Isle of Man the game between Kramnik and
Tariana now in this position
Tariana played Knight d4 who would you
say is better in this position
yeah Black is better
he's better because of the domination of
his pieces now kramnik took on d4e takes
d4 and now he plays a move you'd never
guess which is not in not bad but
surprising and as it turns out not good
so one other moves would be like Queen
takes b3 and the position would be
around slightly better for Kramnik but
is not that bad for white so black
played Bishop f3
but taryeong calculated further and he
found the reputation
and Bishop takes F 3 and F queen takes F
1
yes Bishop e2 and suddenly kremlings
queen is trapped now I have to add that
this game was extra dramatic cuz Kramnik
who's number 2 in the world so don't
forget that Tyrion was playing Kramnik
number 2 in the world who was trying to
qualify for the candidates and still has
some theoretical chances before this
game but not much after this one because
this win from Tariana basically takes
all the chances away from Kramnik for
qualifying for the candidates at least
through rating points so he goes for
night takes g3f takes g3 Queen f1 now
tarean plays a very nice consolidating
move and in positions when you're better
or near winning it's important to learn
how to consolidate and that Tariana does
very very well
Bishop f2 and this Bishop f2 is very
smooth because it defends the f3 Bishop
the Yvonne Bishop simultaneously also
giving the option for kramnik to
exchange Queens which she really doesn't
want so he plays queen d3 rook c3 Queen
at 5 and I really like this move
what torreón plays here a very good
technical move
what did Taran play King g2 a very good
move in winning positions it's very
important to connect your pieces because
it's easy to make a mess of winning
positions let's say ah I see a winning
fork here Bishop g4 but all I've learned
there the bishop that's how easy it is
to mess up winning positions so King g2
is a very good move saying okay I see
this Bishop g4 idea but first I defend
the f2 Bishop rook f6 and notice that
kramnik is still trying to put some
pressure and that's what you need to do
when you're kind of in trouble try to
place for some tricks just try to put
some pressure on your opponent Queen c2
offering an exchange because it would be
a good deal no no thank you
g4 another a good move what is basically
stopping any active counter play of
pieces with g4 no more Queen f5 ideas
normal ideas of sacrificing or anything
on the King side rook c6 inviting for an
exchange
should be obliged should we exchange or
should we make a different move
please rook c5 now the idea is that he
doesn't want to build the center for
kramnik because if you take B takes the
d5 bond is not weak anymore and if we're
getting really objective in this
position black is only a pawn and a rook
for two bishops so why does clearly
winning but if he gets an extra pawn or
he gets to exchange many pieces he can
eventually hope for a fortress or a draw
I mean getting a fortress and then
eventually drawn so Torian doesn't want
a fortress he wants a passer so he puts
pressure on the d5 pawn and eventually
he'll get kramnik to do some exchanges
because this pawn is basically hard to
defend without a pawn protection rook d8
and how can we put some more pressure on
the d5 pawn remember if you have some
extra material exchanging pieces is a
good idea
Queen f5 exactly that's what James sorry
on plate now if black starts to exchange
everything that wouldn't be a great
achievement for him but he has no choice
because the d5 is too weak and if he
loses that pawn white will get a passed
pawn supported by the bishops which is
just losing so rook c5 Queen takes d7 d
takes e5 d4 and now as we saw in
previous games
Tariana knows what is the strongest
piece in the endgame and you should know
to the king so what should white play
here yes he Bing brings the King to e1
exactly to d1 King f1 d3 King he won as
you said the two King do you want and
sadly for kramnik that's the finish line
for the pawn and it's just gonna get
gobbled up King f8 and now when you have
bishops you can steal diagonals and
lines and that's what tie on does with
Bishop g3 King g7 Bishop d6 check and
you can see that the fun is about to be
over for Kramnik king g6 King takes d to
be sex King III takes takes and now
black would have some chances of holding
if not for this extra beep on that will
be promoted with the help of the bishops
now there is one thing that white really
needs to be careful with he needs to
exchange as minimally as possible so he
plays b4 that exchange is good for him
because he wants to push the pawn up to
b7 and the win but f5 comes b5 well this
is the pawn exchange he can't really
avoid so he doesn't react on the King
side takes takes g6
b6 h 5 and now he plays g5 because if he
would start
changing the last ponds black might have
the theoretical idea of sacrificing the
rook for the pawn and a bishop and then
it would be a draw but tarean says and
no I'll keep upon for later and then
he'll win because the two bishops will
just win against the king the lone King
so black played King d7 b7 and the
bishop ace of an idea is unstoppable
and therefore kramnik resigned that's
how I am beat kramnik number 2 of the
world after retirement
[Music]
you
[Music]